في ماسات وتروكاديرو شارع سيبيريا
العام في نهائي فرنسا هو
حليف الطريق تينغ بيرتراريا
الديمقراطيون والوحيدون في حليمي ومايا
رودولف والمخدرات ولكن لا
العدالة المسؤولة والجبانة هي
أعمى
العدالة تتظاهر بعدم الرؤية
الجريمة واضحة وبالطبع
تجنب أي نقاش نمرر
الناس للحمقى مارك ماتواكي من هذا القبيل
ريما الأسرة المنكوبة ستكون لنا
المفضل على الخبز المحمص في INRA الذي يرمي بعيدا
وكانت أصابعهم القذرة المريلة و
إسرائيل لديها التبغ في الضوء
حتى أنه كان قوياً بما فيه الكفاية فهو صديق فرانسيا لينا
لافيت هو العرف للذهاب إلى آل
harra roll france إلى auch في
شهر الكافتيريا نحن على الويب وسنكون و
ليون ولكن القتل عليه أن ض
نطلب مراجعة هذه المحاكمة
جئت إلى كرة القدم
يجب أن تكون إسرائيل مواطنة فرنسية
الآبار، أخبر لوماني الخاص بك
الفيفا في مسقط رأسه وشيك
شارون ثم المرشح المثالي ماركهام ول
أوروبا عبر أوكرانيا